This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Early in the morning on August 17th, 1999, an earthquake struck northwestern Turkey. It was the first of two earthquakes that would devastate that nation and parts of Greece. Whole cities were reduced to rubble. Thousands of people were killed and hundreds of thousands were left homeless.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹坦。1999年8月17日清晨，一场地震袭击了土耳其西北部。这是将重创该国及希腊部分地区的两场地震中的第一场。整座城市沦为废墟。数千人丧生，数十万人无家可归。
Amid the destruction, however, something extraordinary happened. Turkish rescue workers saved a Greek child from the wreckage of a building. A Greek man offered to donate a kidney to someone in Turkey. And the Greek foreign minister, George Papandreo, called on his fellow Greeks to offer aid. I heard the news and the media immediately asked me,
然而，在满目疮痍之中，发生了一件非同寻常的事。土耳其救援人员从一栋建筑的废墟中救出了一名希腊儿童。一名希腊男子主动提出向一名土耳其人捐赠肾脏。希腊外长乔治·帕潘德里欧则呼吁同胞们提供援助。我听到这个消息后，媒体立刻问我：
have you sent a statement? And I said, you know, I sent a statement, but I want to say something more. Why don't we help the Turks? Why don't we give blood? What made this remarkable is that Greece and Turkey have long had a rocky relationship, marked by periods of open warfare and animosity. But George Papandreos saw an opportunity for rapprochema between the two nations.
“你发声明了吗？”我说：“你知道的，我发了声明，但我还想说点别的。我们为什么不帮帮土耳其人？我们为什么不献血呢？”这件事之所以引人注目，是因为希腊和土耳其长期以来关系紧张，屡经公开交火和敌意。但乔治·帕潘德里欧看到了两国实现关系正常化的契机。
I felt this was a real issue, but it was also a political act. The idea of blood, of course, has a much deeper symbolism. The interesting thing, which I hadn't expected, was there was an outpour of help. In the weeks that followed, the blood drive intervention and other aid efforts transformed the way many Greeks and Turks saw each other. They began to view each other not as enemies, but as fellow victims of a terrible disaster. Very quickly, this sentiment spilled over into new domains. So then all of a sudden you saw things coming out which you know we would never expect it. So cookbooks that are Greek Turkish cookbooks. Of course, why not? We have competitions who makes better Baklava.
我觉得这是一个真正的问题，但它也是一种政治行为。当然，“血”这个概念具有更深层的象征意义。有趣的是，我没有料到会有如此汹涌的援助之潮。在随后的几周里，献血行动和其他救援努力改变了许多希腊人和土耳其人对彼此的看法。他们开始不再把对方视为敌人，而是看作一场可怕灾难中的同命相连者。很快，这种情绪便蔓延到了新的领域。突然之间，你看到了一些你认为绝不会出现的事物，比如希腊-土耳其双语食谱。当然，为什么不呢？我们甚至还要举行比赛，看看谁做果仁蜜饼更好吃。
Then we had TV series where the Turkish man or Turkish woman would fall in love with a Greek woman or a Greek man. So these soap operas that were became very popular. The blood drive reframed the relationship. It was a psychological intervention and it was powerful. Today we're going to look at a similar psychological intervention. It targets one of America's most pressing social challenges. The way in which radical social change takes place is a step and a step and a step and and a step, and a step, and then a fall.
接着我们有了电视剧，土耳其男子或女子会爱上希腊女子或男子。这些肥皂剧变得非常受欢迎。献血行动重构了两国关系。这是一种心理干预，而且力量强大。今天，我们将探讨一种类似的心理干预。它针对的是美国最紧迫的社会挑战之一。根本的社会变革是一步、一步、一步、又一步，然后是一个挫折。
How changing the frame around a problem can make the seemingly impossible possible. This week on Hidden Brain. Most Americans have strong and automatic reactions to news reports involving police shootings. Some of us are outraged, some defensive. All of us feel exhausted. It often feels like we are stuck between two camps, one that's outraged about the police, and another that's outraged that we are outraged about the police, and another that's outraged that we are outraged about the police. At Yale University, psychologists Philip Attiba Gough has come at the problem in a novel
如何围绕问题改变框架，能将看似不可能的事情变为可能。本周收听《隐藏的大脑》。大多数美国人对涉及警察枪击事件的新闻报道都会产生强烈且自动的反应。我们有些人感到愤怒，有些人则进行防御。所有人都感到精疲力竭。人们常常觉得我们陷入了两个阵营的对立之中，一方对警察感到愤怒，另一方则对我们对警察感到愤怒而感到愤怒，还有一方则对我们对警察感到愤怒而感到愤怒。在耶鲁大学，心理学家菲利普·阿蒂巴·戈夫以一种新颖的方式切入了这个
way. His data show there are indeed racial disparities in how policing unfolds in many communities. Disparities tied not to the occurrence of crime or the prevalence of poverty, but the choices that police officers make. What makes his work unusual is how he thinks we should fix the problem. His novel approach has produced that rarest of things, consensus between police and communities, and actual change.
问题。他的数据表明，在许多社区中，警务执法方式确实存在种族差异。这些差异并非与犯罪发生率或贫困普遍程度有关，而是源于警官所做出的选择。他的工作之所以与众不同，在于他认为我们应该如何解决这个问题。他新颖的方法取得了极其罕见的成果——警察与社区之间达成共识，并实现了真正的变革。
Philip Patiba-Goff, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Philip, back in 2007, you were starting out as a young faculty member at Penn State. You attended a conference with academics and law enforcement officers. There was a well-dressed black woman sitting in the back of the room.
菲利普·帕蒂巴-戈夫，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。菲利普，早在2007年，你刚开始担任宾夕法尼亚州立大学的青年教员时，曾参加过一个由学者和执法人员出席的会议。当时教室后排坐着一位衣着考究的黑人女性。
She was a senior officer in the Denver Police Department. You went up to say hello to her, and she said something odd in response. What did she say? Yeah, I went up to her because she was sitting by herself and I wanted to make her feel welcome so I asked if I could sit down and she told me that I lacked the moral fortitude to do anything real with my life. So that's an odd thing to say to someone you're meeting for the first time. The woman's name was Tracy Kazee and she was essentially throwing down a challenge to you as an academic. Give me the context for her remark. So there was a 15 year old boy who was suffering
她是丹佛警察局的高级警官。你走过去跟她打招呼，她却说了一句奇怪的话作为回应。她说了什么？是的，我走过去是因为她一个人坐着，我想让她感到自在，所以我问能不能坐下，而她却告诉我，我缺乏做出一些真正有意义的生活改变所需的道德毅力。对一个初次见面的人说这种话确实很奇怪。这位女性名叫特蕾西·卡齐，她本质上是以学者的身份向你发起挑战。请为她的言论提供一些背景信息。当时有一个15岁的男孩患有
from mental illness. He grabbed a knife allegedly because he was frustrated. He couldn't communicate with his family. His family got scared. They called law enforcement law enforcement showed up and killed this boy in his own home. At a town hall meeting that followed African American woman asked Tracy, do you train your officers to kill young black men? And this is a slam dunk from a PR perspective. It's an easy question. You just say no and move on. But because of who Tracy is, she actually heard the question. She wanted to know the answer and she realized and then set out loud. I don't know. So after that incident, she spent the next two years trying to figure out who could help her answer that question.
精神疾病。据说他因为无法与家人沟通而感到沮丧，于是抓起了一把刀。他的家人感到害怕，便报了警。执法人员赶到现场，在这个男孩自己的家中将其击毙。在随后的市民大会上，一位非裔美国女性问特蕾西：“你们训练警官去杀害年轻的黑人男性吗？”从公关的角度来看，这是一个稳赢的问题。这是一个简单的问题，你只要说“不”然后继续就行了。但由于特蕾西的为人，她真的听进去了这个问题。她想知道答案，并意识到这一点，然后大声说出来：“我不知道。”因此，在事件发生后，她花了两年的时间去寻找能够帮她解答这个问题的人。
She wanted someone to work with who would not care about how long it took to get the answers. And she was frustrated, I think, by the fact that the academy was not set up to help people answer those kinds of questions. So she found me and we began to try and answer not just that question, but the deeper questions of what do you do with the reality of racism in the context of public safety? The boy who was killed was Paul Childs and the incident happened in Denver in 2003. Philip and Tracy said, I don't know, to the question, does your police department train officers to kill young black men? What I'm hearing is that she felt they might be something structural
她想找一个不在乎花多久时间来寻找答案的合作伙伴。我想她感到沮丧的是，学术界并没有做好准备来帮助人们解答这类问题。于是她找到了我，我们开始不仅尝试回答那个问题，还要回答更深层次的问题：在公共安全的背景下，你该如何面对种族主义的现实？被杀害的男孩名叫保罗·柴尔斯，事件发生于2003年的丹佛。菲利普和特蕾西对“你们的警察局是否训练警官杀害年轻的黑人男性”这个问题回答了“我不知道”。我听到的是，她觉得在警察的实际做法中，可能存在某种结构性的东西，
embedded in police practices that made it more likely that an officer might kill a young black man. in police practices that made it more likely that an officer might kill a young black man? It wasn't just, hey, yeah, maybe there's some structural stuff going on. Maybe the training is having this unintended consequence. It was how on earth have we been doing this in this country for 100 plus year? We haven't bothered to answer that question. And in most places, we haven't bothered to ask it of the people who have the capacity to make sure there's an answer. There's a kind of neglect, a negligence, in the way that we've asked questions of our
使得警官更有可能杀死一名年轻的黑人男性。这不仅仅是说，“嘿，也许有些结构性问题正在发生。也许这种培训带来了这种意想不到的后果。”而是“我们到底是怎么在这个国家以这种方式度过了一百多年，却一直懒得去回答这个问题？”在大多数地方，我们甚至懒得去问那些有能力确保得到答案的人。在提出我们的
public safety that reveals that we haven't centered the experiences of the people who fear getting killed by the folks who respond when you call out in crisis. That was a lot of the frustration that I know that she felt in that moment. In the year since that meeting, you and Tracy Kuzi have set up a national organization. We're going to talk at length about the work you've done, but I want to start by establishing the context for your work. Many of us feel a sense of hopelessness
公共安全问题时，存在着一种忽视和疏忽，这表明我们并没有以那些在危机中呼叫救援时，害怕被执法人员杀害的人们的体验为中心。我知道她在当时感到了极大的沮丧。自从那次会议以来的这些年里，你和特蕾西·卡齐建立了一个全国性组织。我们接下来会详细讨论你们所做的工作，但我首先想为你的工作奠定背景。当我们听到有关歧视和警务的新闻时，许多人都会感到一种绝望感。
when we hear about discrimination and policing. You say that one reason for this hopelessness is that for the last 250 years, we have defined the problem wrong. We have defined the problem in a way that effectively makes the problem unsolvable. What do you mean by that? So if the problem is individual character inside hearts and minds, a defect of the soul that we've got to fix.
你说造成这种绝望感的原因之一是，在过去250年里，我们一直把问题定义错了。我们对问题的定义方式，实际上让这个问题变得无法解决。你这是什么意思？如果问题出在每个人内心深处的个人品格上，出在我们必须修复的心灵缺陷上，
There are many problems with that, the first of which of course is that it doesn't track particularly closely with the science, but probably more importantly, it's just a hard problem to fix. And then we're having a conversation about a thing that is almost impossible to reliably measure. There's no saliva test to be like, nope, like you're 45% racist. So now you definitely gotta go to the reeducation center.
那么这其中存在很多问题，首先也是最明显的一点，就是它与科学并不十分吻合；但可能更重要的是，这本身就是一个极难解决的问题。接着，我们在讨论一件几乎无法可靠衡量的事情。没有什么唾液测试能显示：“不，你含有45%的种族主义，所以你现在必须去再教育中心。”
Like there's no way to really know. And even if you could, then you've maybe fixed the one person. And that's not gonna work across 18,000 law enforcement agencies in this country. And that's just law enforcement. Forget about everybody who's got access to 911 and can use law enforcement as their personal racism concierge.
真的没有办法确切知道。即便你真的测出来了，你也可能只修复了那一个人。这在全美18000个执法机构中是行不通的。这还只是执法机构，更不用说那些能够拨打911、并将执法人员当作个人种族主义管家的所有人了。
So it creates layers of difficulty at solving the problem from the difficulty detecting it to the ability to actually change hearts and minds. And that is exhausting. When you look at how often we have racism producing outcomes that are so tragic as to make you have to shut down your whole life for a day or a week or a month or longer. Forget about the country. I want to look at three examples from the news
因此，它在解决问题时制造了多层困难，从发现问题的难度到真正改变人们内心的能力。这让人精疲力竭。当你审视种族主义导致悲惨结局的频率时，那些悲剧甚至迫使你不得不暂停整整一天、一周、一个月甚至更长时间的生活，更不用说整个国家了。我想从新闻中看三个例子，
that illustrate how we have long thought about the problem of disparities in policing. Later in the show, we look at how redefining the problem can help us rethink those challenges. In March of 2021, two police officers responded to reports of gunfire in the Chicago neighborhood Little Village. They changed a suspect, Adam Toledo, down a dark alley. Can you tell me what happened next? Yeah, Adam Toledo was the boy.
它们说明了我们长期以来是如何思考警务差异问题的。在节目後半部分，我们将探讨重新定义问题如何帮助我们重新思考这些挑战。2021年3月，两名警官前往芝加哥小村庄社区回应枪击报告。他们在一条黑暗的小巷里追捕一名嫌疑人亚当·托莱多。你能告诉我接下来发生了什么吗？是的，亚当·托莱多就是那个男孩。
He was hanging out with somebody else who allegedly had fired a gun. That individual was closer to adulthood, handed the gun to Adam Toledo, who ran away, and then when realizing that law enforcement was close tried to dispose of the gun in a way that he wouldn't get in trouble. The officer saw the gun, saw it flash and move, and then killed Adam Toledo. I remember there was a huge debate about the case. Some people said shooting a 13 year old child simply unacceptable.
他当时和另一个人在一起，后者据称开过枪。那个人年龄稍大一些，把枪交给了亚当·托莱多。亚当逃跑了，当意识到执法人员逼近时，他试图处理掉枪以免惹上麻烦。警官看到了枪，看到它闪光并移动，随后便开枪打死了亚当·托莱多。我记得当时关于这个案子有巨大的争论。有些人说，向一个13岁的孩子开枪是绝对不可接受的。
Nothing more to discuss. Others said, hang on, the police could not have known that he was 13, and Adam Toledo looked like he was armed. The officer had to make a split second decision. He did not know if Adam Toledo was raising his arms to surrender or raising his arms to open fire. So each side not only feels they are right, but that the other is unsympathetic, irrational, maybe even evil.
没什么好讨论的。另一些人则说，等一下，警察不可能知道他才13岁，而且亚当·托莱多看起来像是武装人员。警官必须在电光石火之间做出决定。他不知道亚当·托莱多举起双手是为了投降，还是为了开火。因此，双方不仅觉得自己是对的，还觉得对方缺乏同理心、不理智，甚至可能是邪恶的。
That's exactly right. And this is one of the reasons why this becomes impossible. You start seeing this from the officer's perspective and in Chicago in particular, you have an armed populace. You don't know the age of the person. You know that they're running away. You know that they're probably faster than you. So there's a chance that they're going to get around the corner and then wait for you. You clearly see a weapon.
完全正确。这也是让这件事情变得不可能的原因之一。你开始从警察的角度来看待这个问题，特别是在芝加哥，你面对的是一个拥枪的人口。你不知道对方的年龄。你知道他们在逃跑。你知道他们可能比你跑得快。所以他们很有可能会绕过拐角然后埋伏你。你清楚地看到了一把武器。
You know that there was supposed to be a weapon present. The person is turning to face you. And now I got to make a decision. And if I'm wrong and they've got a gun and they're pointing it at me, that's the last mistake I ever get to make. There is a saying in law enforcement, I'd rather be tried by 12 than carried by six. And so you make the decision that makes sure you go home at the end of the day, because the majority of people you're dealing with are people
你知道现场本该有一把武器。这个人正转身面对你。现在我必须做出决定。如果我猜错了，他们有枪并且正指着我，那将是我这辈子犯下的最后一个错误。执法界有一句名言：“我宁愿由12个人审判，也不愿由6个人抬着。”因此，你做出的决定是为了确保自己能在一天结束时平安回家，因为你所面对的大多数人，都是你认为
who you think want to hurt you. And from a community perspective, every piece of that seems sociopathic and homicidal. There is a scared 13 year old boy who has been burdened by an older person with trying to make sure that our incredibly cool criminal legal system doesn't catch him too. And while complying with the the asks of every adult around him, he's executed. Here to me is the crux of the whole thing. If we can't imagine that we could have prevented that situation in the first place, it's our failure of imagination that gets kids like Adam Toledo killed. Let's look at another case that shows a different facet of the problem, Philip.
想要伤害你的人。但在社区看来，这其中的每一处都显得反社会且充满杀戮。现场有一个吓坏了的13岁男孩，他被一个成年人连累，试图确保我们这个令人难以置信冷酷的刑事司法系统不会抓到他。而在听从周围每个成年人要求的过程中，他被处决了。在我看来，这才是整个事件的核心所在。如果我们无法想象我们本可以在一开始就阻止那种情况的发生，正是我们想象力的缺乏，才导致了亚当·托莱多这样的孩子丧命。让我们看看另一个展现问题不同侧面的案例，菲利普。
In Brooklyn, Center, Minnesota, police stopped Dante Wright for having expired car registration tags. Now many listeners will be familiar with the story since the police officer involved was recently found guilty of manslaughter. But tell us what happened when the police pulled Dante over. So the senior officer who is also a training officer is trying to restrain Dante Wright as Dante Wright is trying to get away.
在明尼苏达州布鲁克林森特，警察因汽车登记标签过期拦下了丹特·赖特。许多听众对这个故事会很熟悉，因为涉案警察最近被裁定过失杀人罪名成立。但请告诉我们，警察拦下丹特时发生了什么。当时，身为高级警官兼培训教官的警察正试图控制丹特·赖特，而丹特·赖特则试图挣脱。
And that senior officer then calls out Taser, Taser, Taser. That's what you're supposed to do when you grab the Taser to let everybody know there's an energy controlled weapon, let them get clear. She does not, in fact, grab the Taser. She grabs her firearm, shoots and kills Dante Wright. So I feel in the aftermath of these incidents,
这位高级警官随后大喊：“泰瑟枪！泰瑟枪！泰瑟枪！”当你拔出泰瑟枪时，你就该这么做，以让所有人知道这里有一把能量控制武器，让他们退避。然而，她实际上并没有抓泰瑟枪。她抓起自己的随身武器，开枪打死了丹特·赖特。所以我觉得在这些事件发生之后，
there are often multiple claims and counterclaims. Dante Wright's mother said he called her during the incident and said he'd been pulled over because he had air fresheners hanging from his rearview mirror. Now, that sounds like a trivial infraction, and many people concluded it showed the police had malicious intent. But I want to play you a clip from Brooklyn Center Police Chief Tim Ganon at a news conference
往往会出现多种说法和反驳。丹特·赖特的母亲说，他在事发期间给她打过电话，说自己被拦下来是因为后视镜上挂了空气清新剂。听起来这是一个微不足道的违规行为，许多人因此断定这表明警察抱有恶意。但我放一段布鲁克林森特警察局长蒂姆·加农在枪击事件后不久举行的新闻发布会上的录音给你听。
shortly after the shooting. It is my belief that the officer had the intention to deploy their taser, but instead shot Mr. Wright with a single bullet. Disappears to me, from what I've viewed in the officer's reaction and distress immediately after that this was an accidental discharge that resulted in the tragic death of Mr. Wright. So the family saying look who pulls over someone for hanging air fresheners in their car. It's racist cops of course. The police say no-no-no the cop was distressed after the shooting. This proves she could not have been racist.
我相信这位警官的本意是使用泰瑟枪，但却用一颗子弹击中了赖特先生。从我所看到的警官在事发后的反应和痛苦来看，这似乎是一起意外走火，导致了赖特先生的悲惨死亡。所以家属会说：“瞧瞧，谁会因为车里挂了空气清新剂就把人拦下来？这当然是种族主义警察干的。”警察则说：“不不不，警察在枪击后感到很痛苦。这证明她绝不可能是种族主义者。”
And almost instantly we start arguing about what's happening inside the police officer's mind. That's exactly it. And I think one of the ways that it's important to understand the way that we do race in the United States, we've got scripts. If I tell you a story, and there is an attractive woman walking her dog, the dog pulls on the leash and she falls down and then a very attractive gentleman who probably has a British accent goes to help her up and she's embarrassed. Where are we? We're clearly in the middle of a romantic comedy and that was a meet-cute. We don't just have genres for movies, we have genres for the stories that play out in our
几乎转瞬间，我们就开始争论警察脑子里到底在想什么。完全正确。我认为，理解美国种族问题的一种重要方式是，我们都有剧本。如果我给你讲一个故事，有一个迷人的女人在遛狗，狗拉着牵引绳，她摔倒了，然后一个非常迷人的绅士（可能带着英国口音）走过去扶她起来，而她感到很尴尬。我们身在何处？我们显然置身于一部浪漫喜剧中，这是一次浪漫的邂逅。我们不仅有电影的类型，我们的社会中上演的故事也有类型。
society. And the story, the tragic awful killing of Dante Wright and the killing of Tamir Rice and the killing of Adam Toledo, we quickly put that inside of genres where the relative question is, how sinister is the officer, how deserving of death was the victim. And those are terrible genres to help us write the narratives that get us out of here, which is why the definition of racism is so much part of the problem. If that's not our definition, we have to tell different stories. Controversial cases involving police shootings of black people often devolve into discussions
而关于丹特·赖特、塔米尔·赖斯以及亚当·托莱多的悲惨杀戮，我们很快就把这些故事塞进了一些类型里，其中的相对问题变成了：这个警察有多险恶？受害者有多该死？这些都是糟糕的类型，无助于我们写出让我们摆脱困境的叙事，这也是为什么对种族主义的定义成了问题的一部分。如果这不是我们的定义，我们就必须讲述不同的故事。涉及警察枪击黑人事件的争议案件，往往会退化为关于意图和品格的讨论。
about intentions and character. As we confront case after case, our framing causes us to reach for sweeping conclusions that reflect our growing sense of despair. This is what happened after police in Louisville, Kentucky, used a no-knock warrant to enter the home of 26-year-old medical technician, Breonna Taylor. My understanding is, they went into a house that they thought people were distributing drugs. They thought that there might be armed conflict once they entered and that those who were in the house were going to be a flight risk. Those are the criteria often that law enforcement uses to request a no-knock warrant so that
当我们直面一个又一个案件时，我们的框架导致我们得出席卷一切的结论，反映出我们日益增长的绝望感。肯塔基州路易斯维尔的警察使用“不敲门搜查令”闯入26岁医疗技术员布伦娜·泰勒的家后，情况就是如此。据我所知，他们闯入了一所他们认为有人在贩毒的房子。他们认为一旦进入，可能会发生武装冲突，而且屋里的人有潜逃的风险。这些通常是执法人员申请“不敲门搜查令”的标准，这样他们就可以
they can enter without announcing themselves in advance other than to say, here we are, we're Louisville PD, now your door is kicked in and we are in your house. Brianna Taylor's boyfriend opened fire when he thought intruders were breaking into the home. The police fired back and killed Brianna. Shortly afterwards, a grand jury declined to indict the officers. Here's how Brianna Taylor's family attorney Benjamin Crump responded. It underscores what we have been saying all alone. There seems to be two justice systems in America, one for black America and one for white America. Philip, you're sleeping inside your own home. You wake up to the sounds of people breaking
在不事先表明身份的情况下进入，除了说：“我们来了，我们是路易斯维尔警察局，现在你的门被踢开了，我们在你家了。”布伦娜·泰勒的男友以为有入侵者破门而入，于是开枪反击。警察开枪还击并打死了布伦娜。不久之后，大陪审团拒绝起诉涉案警察。布伦娜·泰勒的家族律师本杰明·克鲁普是这样回应的：这强调了我们一直以来所说的话。美国似乎存在两个司法系统，一个是为黑人美国准备的，另一个是为白人美国准备的。菲利普，你正睡在自己的家中，突然被破门而入的声音惊醒。
in. Seconds later, there's a gunfight and you end up shot to death. From the point of view of the black community, it's easy to feel that the system is rigged against you. Yeah, there are particulars to the charging in that case that were incredibly bleak. And I should clarify here, there are multiple black communities, many of whom saw Breonna Taylor's fate as something that could have happened to them. I'm glad you pointed out there are many black communities. As a black man yourself, Philip, have you ever had to worry about a police officer pulling
几秒钟后，爆发了枪战，你最终中枪身亡。从黑人社区的角度来看，很容易觉得这个系统是对你不利的。是的，该案中的指控细节确实极其惨淡。我在这里应该澄清一下，有许多不同的黑人社区，其中许多社区将布伦娜·泰勒的命运视为可能发生在他门自己身上的事。我很高兴你指出存在许多黑人社区。作为一名黑人男性，菲利普，你曾担心过警察会对你拔枪吗？
a weapon on you? I'm a black man in America, so of course I have. Even once while I was shadowing law enforcement to learn how they did it. I was mistaken for a protester, an approach aggressively by law enforcement, and I had to have a captain step in and be like, if you put a harm, one of the very, very few hairs on this man's head, there will be problems. If you're black in the United States, and this hasn't happened to you, you were living a vanishingly rare life. And of course, as anger the police has grown in many communities, the police feel increasingly
我是美国的黑人男性，所以当然担心过。甚至有一次，我在跟随执法人员暗访以了解他们是如何工作时，被误认为是一名抗议者，遭到执法人员的强力逼近，最后不得不由一位队长出面干预并说道：“如果你敢动这名男子头上的哪怕一根、一根、一根头发，就会有麻烦了。”如果你在美国是黑人，而这种事没有发生在你身上，那你过着一种极其罕见的生活。当然，随着许多社区对警察的愤怒与日俱增，警察也感到越来越
betrayed. I want to play you a clip from former Milwaukee police chief Ed Flynn. All of those issues are magnified by what's basically been an unrelenting campaign to de-legitimize, stigmatize and dehumanize America's police officers. I think a climate has been created in which the deranged as well as the career criminal well-armed feel emboldened to engage their desires to basically assassinate police officers. Setting aside by the police I write or wrong to feel this way, is it accurate Philip from your experience working with police departments to say that many officers feel like they are under siege?
被背叛。我想放一段前密尔沃基警察局长埃德·弗林的录音给你听。所有这些问题都被一场基本上毫不留情的运动放大了，这场运动旨在将美国的警务人员非合法化、污名化和非人化。我认为已经营造出这样一种氛围：那些精神失常的人以及装备精良的职业罪犯感到受到了鼓舞，去实施他们暗杀警察的欲望。抛开警察这种感觉是对是错不谈，菲利普，根据你与警察局合作的经验，说许多警察觉得自己如临大敌，这准确吗？
Yeah, I think that's the right way to frame it. Moral amongst law enforcement is lower than I've ever seen it. Moral among black officers is particularly low because they live frequently with other black people. They go home frequently to black communities, and they catch all of the invective from those communities, and they feel it. And then they show up to a department that wants to erase or dismiss the critiques that they themselves often have. The rift between police departments and black Americans can feel impossible to bridge, and yet, in working with individual departments across the country, Philip has found ways to begin to make progress.
是的，我认为这是正确的界定方式。执法人员的士气是我见过最低的一次。黑人警官的士气尤其低落，因为他们经常与其他人一起生活。他们经常回到黑人社区，承受来自这些社区的所有谩骂，并且感同身受。然后他们回到一个想要抹杀或驳回他们自己也常有的批评的部门。警察局与美国黑人之间的鸿沟似乎不可逾越，然而，通过与全国各地的各个警察局合作，菲利普找到了开始取得进展的方法。
That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Many of us carry around a model of what it means to be a racist. That model usually involves reading the mind of the person, drawing conclusions about their intentions, their motivations, their animosities. At Yale University, psychologist Philipp Petiba-Goff has been asking a different question. Instead of spending hours fruitlessly arguing about a police officer's intentions, what happens if we focus less on her character and
我们稍后回来。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹坦。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹坦。我们许多人都怀有一种关于“种族主义者”意味着什么的模式。这种模式通常包括揣摩个人的心思，对他们的意图、动机和敌意得出结论。在耶鲁大学，心理学家菲利普·帕蒂巴-戈夫一直在提出一个不同的问题。如果我们把花在毫无结果地争论警察意图上的时间减少，转而少关注她的品格，
more on her actions? Philip, many police officers say the tragedies we hear about in the news are outliers. You've studied police use of force among white and non-white suspects. Does the data show systematic differences in how police treat blacks versus whites? Of course, the data revealed that. The first step in answering that question is, are there disparities and there are massive disparities? The second question, which is immediately harder, is how much of those disparities are
多关注她的行为，会发生什么呢？菲利普，许多警察说我们在新闻中听到的悲剧只是特例。你研究过警察对白人和非白人嫌疑人的武力使用情况。数据是否显示警察对待黑人和白人的方式存在系统性差异？当然，数据显示了这一点。回答这个问题的第一步是：是否存在差异？答案是存在巨大的差异。第二个问题立刻变得更具挑战性：这些差异中有多少是由警察确实无法、也不应当被要求控制的因素造成的？
driven by things police really can't and shouldn't be asked to control? Things like poverty or crime. And in fact, if we think that racism doesn't just exist in policing, which by the way, it doesn't. It exists in education, in housing, in employment, in healthcare, so that crime is a lagging indicator of other forms of racism. In other words, you can make the argument that,
比如贫困或犯罪。事实上，如果我们认为种族主义不仅存在于警务中（顺便说一句，它确实不只存在于此），它还存在于教育、住房、就业、医疗保健中，那么犯罪率就是其他形式种族主义滞后的指标。换句话说，你可以这样认为：
hey, racism's bigger than just police, and that bigger racism is driving some of these disparities. So what part belongs to the police and what part doesn't? The answer is simply poverty and crime are insufficient to explain racial disparities in a police use of force, stops, arrests, or other burdensome police behaviors. What we see is that black folks across the country, about four times more likely to have force used on them than white folks. When you control for crime and poverty, black folks are in our data somewhere between one
嘿，种族主义的范围比单纯的警察要大，而那种更广泛的种族主义正在推动其中一些差异。那么，哪部分属于警察，哪部分不属于？答案很简单，贫困和犯罪不足以解释警察在武力使用、拦车、逮捕或其他繁重警务行为中的种族差异。我们看到的是，全国各地的黑人遭受武力对待的可能性大约是白人的四倍。当你控制了犯罪和贫困变量后，在我们的数据中，黑人遭遇武力的可能性在
and a half times as likely and 16 times as likely. Sometimes it gets worse because of the spatial distribution of law enforcement. So Philip, when we look at data like that, it's easy to conclude that racism has to be behind these disparities, but you once wrote, there is mounting evidence that racial discrimination can occur, even absent racial bigotry,
1.5倍到16倍之间。有时，由于执法力度的空间分布，情况会变得更糟。所以，菲利普，当我们看到这样的数据时，很容易断定种族主义一定是这些差异背后的原因，但你曾写道：“越来越多的证据表明，即使没有种族偏见（无论是公开的还是隐蔽的），种族歧视也可能发生。”
either overt or covert. What do you mean by that? Yeah, and so I just want to reframe just a little bit that question. It is racism. It just doesn't have to be bigotry, right? Bigotry and prejudice, that's inside. I want us to get that racism is that pattern of behaviors out in the world. So for instance, what a family is dealing with someone who is in the midst of mental health
你这话是什么意思？是的，我想稍微重新界定一下这个问题。这就是种族主义。它只是不一定非得是偏见，对吧？偏见和成见存在于内心。我想让我们明白，种族主义是世界上存在的那些行为模式。例如，当一个家庭在处理处于精神健康危机中的某人时，
crisis. They may try and talk to someone. They may try and reach out for help to someone at a hospital. They may try and set something up for a clinic. When that family member who is in mental distress doesn't want to go. We don't have any resources that are available to the public to help out. What that means is that people have a lot of money, have other folks they can call. They can spend money on private therapy. They can spend money for family counseling. People without money, the only place to have to call when it gets really bad is 9-1-1.
他们可能会试图与某人交谈。他们可能会试图向医院的人寻求帮助。他们可能会试图为诊所安排一些事情。当那个处于精神困境的家庭成员不想去时，我们没有任何可供公众使用的资源来提供帮助。这意味着有钱人有其他人可以打电话。他们可以把钱花在私人治疗上，可以把钱花在家庭咨询上。而对于没有钱的人来说，当情况变得真的很糟糕时，他们唯一能打的电话就是911。
And 9-1-1 has three options, a fire, ambulance, or a badge and a gun. And so that's how without needing to dislike black people, it may, in fact, black family members, as it was in the case of Paul Childs, who cry out for help. But the way we have structured the system says that the folks who have the least don't get the set of options and resources that would prevent them from needing our systems of punishment to come and take the place of the systems we should have for care. Now we talked earlier about your meeting with Tracy Kazee, the two of you started an organization called the Center for Policing Equity.
而911有三个选项：火警、救护车，或者警徽和枪支。这就是为什么不需要讨厌黑人，也可能会出现像保罗·柴尔斯案那样，黑人家庭成员呼喊求助的情况。但我们构建系统的方式决定了那些一无所有的人无法获得能够阻止他们落入惩罚系统（本该是关怀系统）的选项和资源。我们之前谈到了你与特蕾西·卡齐的会面，你们两人成立了一个名为“警务公平中心”的组织。
And you wanted the focus to be not on what's happening inside the hearts and minds of police officers, but on what they do. You see, there's a long precedent for this idea in policing, at least when it comes to combating crime. That's right. And I wish that I had figured out earlier that there was a really easy way for everyone who's ever worked in an organization to understand it. It's just performance management. That's it. It's nothing more fancy than that. In law enforcement, what they've done for
你们希望关注的焦点不是警察内心的想法，而是他们的行为。你看，这种理念在警务界有着悠久的历史，至少在打击犯罪方面是这样的。没错。我希望我能早点发现，对于任何在组织里工作过的人来说，理解这一点其实非常简单。这就是绩效管理。就是这样。它没有别的更花哨的东西了。在执法部门，
the last, you know, more than quarter century is they've measured crime. And about 80% of law enforcement agencies use something like what's called CompStat. But in its purest forum, the idea is you should be paying attention to crime. If your goal is to prevent it, you should be looking for patterns. And then when you're done finding the patterns, you should be trying to hold yourself accountable for driving down the rates of crime. That's a performance management 101 in any organization. What do you want to get done?
过去四分之一个世纪里，他们一直在衡量犯罪率。大约80%的执法机构都在使用类似“CompStat”（犯罪统计）的东西。但在其最纯粹的形式中，这个理念是你应该关注犯罪。如果你的目标是预防犯罪，你就应该寻找规律。当你找出了规律之后，你就应该努力让自己对压低犯罪率负责。这是任何组织中绩效管理的入门必修课。你想完成什么？
What do you want to avoid? Track it. Hold people accountable to it. So let's see how we can apply this model of performance evaluation to reducing discrimination in policing. In 2011, you got a call from the Las Vegas Police Department. They were confronting accusations that they used force too often. Now, instead of saying, let's examine the character of the officers in the department. Of course, that's hard to measure, hard to change. It's a bad metric for performance evaluation. You looked at the data and found something tangible that could be measured and could be changed. What was it?
你想避免什么？追踪它。让人承担相应的责任。让我们看看如何将这种绩效评估模型应用到减少警务中的歧视上来。2011年，你接到了拉斯维加斯警察局的电话。他们面临着关于他们过于频繁使用武力的指控。现在，与其说“让我们检查一下部门里警察的品格”，因为这当然很难衡量、也很难改变，是绩效评估的糟糕指标，你不如看看数据，找出了可以衡量和改变的实际事物。那是什么？
What we found is that after foot pursuits, we saw a higher rate of use of force across the board. Now, foot pursuit is when someone runs away and the officer takes chase on foot. It's not that complicated. But it's pretty easy when you go back to someone and say, well, what does that feel like? To understand why you get higher rates of force. Because you took off, so I'm running after you. That means my heart rate is up.
我们发现，在步行追捕之后，我们看到全面使用武力的比率更高。步行追捕是指有人逃跑，警官步行追赶。这并不复杂。但当你回过头去问某人“那感觉是什么样的”时，很容易就能理解为什么你会遇到更高的武力使用率。因为你逃跑了，所以我追着你跑。这意味着我的心率上升了。
My adrenaline's going. I know you're a bad guy, because who runs from the Cosmic Bad Guys in the minds of officers. And then if you go around a corner, maybe you have a gun around the corner, or there's a friend who's there to hurt me. So even if you turn around and you say, hey, please don't hurt me and put your hands up, you might be getting a shot to the kidneys for the price of making me run. And so the result in Las Vegas, once we gave that back to law enforcement and back to the community, they said,
我的肾上腺素在飙升。我知道你是个坏人，因为在警察心目中，逃跑的人就是十恶不赦的坏人。然后如果你转过拐角，也许拐角处有一把枪，或者有一个朋友在那里准备伤害我。所以，即使你转过身来说：“嘿，请不要伤害我，举起双手，”你可能也会因为让我跑了而挨上一记重拳。因此在拉斯维加斯，一旦我们将这一结果反馈给执法部门和社区，他们便说：
hey, could you guys just literally take a breath? And that was the comment. That was the spirit that made the change. They said, yeah, we really probably should. So let's train differently. Let's tell folks that they shouldn't touch someone until backup has arrived. They should count to 10, like everybody learns in their marriage counseling.
“嘿，你们能字面意义上地深呼吸一下吗？”这就是当时的评论。这就是促成改变的精神。他们说：“是的，我们确实可能应该这样做。所以让我们进行不同的培训。让我们告诉大家，在支援到达之前，他们不应该触碰任何人。他们应该像每个人在婚姻咨询中学到的那样，数到10。”
Do the things to deescalate your body so you don't end up engaging in unnecessary use of force. That's the language of law enforcement. And the following year, we saw a significant decrease in use of force. My memory is it was 23% that following year and became a national model for how you do experienced based training, all of which goes back to, what's the behavior? What do we think causes the behavior? What's the proximate to the behavior? Can we make a change in the thing that makes that happen?
做那些能让你的身体平静下来的事情，这样你就不会最终卷入不必要的武力使用中。这就是执法部门的语言。第二年，我们看到武力使用显著下降。我的记忆是，第二年下降了23%，并成为如何进行基于经验的培训的全国典范，这一切都归结为：行为是什么？我们认为是什么导致了该行为？什么与该行为密切相关？我们能否改变导致该现象的事情？
That will reduce the incidence of the behavior. I mean, this takes us back to what happened when we discussed the Adam Toledo shooting. Two people are running, it's a dark alley, they're both frightened, they can't see very well, and they have to make split second high stakes decisions. Do this kind of thing regularly, and of course bad things will occur. Now, I want to draw attention to what happens when you don't focus attention on the character of the police officer, instead of saying bad cops shoot kids, if you say, hey, look, foot pursuits increase the risk of tragic mistakes. Let's
这将减少该行为的发生率。我的意思是，这让我们回到了我们讨论亚当·托莱多枪击案时发生的情景。两个人正在奔跑，那是一条黑暗的小巷，他们都很害怕，看不清路，而且必须在电光石火之间做出高风险的决定。经常做这种事情，糟糕的事情自然会发生。现在，我想提请大家注意，当你把注意力集中在警察的品格上，而不是说“坏警察枪杀儿童”，而是说“嘿，看，步行追捕增加了悲惨错误的风险。让我们
try and reduce the number of tragic mistakes in our department. Now, suddenly, cops and community don't find themselves on opposite sides of the equation. They find themselves on the same page. Yeah. So in negotiations and international relations and in business, we talk about the difference between interests and positions. So position is the thing you got to defend, right? If I say, hey, no one can have their shoes on in my house, you got to hold on your sock. You're like, I guess I'm not coming in.
努力减少我们部门内悲惨错误的数量”时会发生什么。突然之间，警察和社区不再发现自己处于对立的两端。他们发现自己有了共识。是的。所以在谈判、国际关系和商业中，我们谈论的是利益和立场之间的区别。立场就是你必须捍卫的东西，对吧？如果我说：“嘿，在我的家里任何人都不准穿鞋，你必须穿着袜子。”你会说：“我想我不进去了。”
But if I say, hey, this is a rug that my parents gave me. It's been the family for a long time. It's real fragile. We ask people to take their shoes off so that we don't mess up the rug. You're like, hey, can I walk around the rug? I'm like, oh yeah, I should've come in the back door. We can fix this.
但如果我说：“嘿，这是我父母送给我的一块地毯。它在这个家里很久了。它真的很脆弱。我们要求人们脱鞋，是为了不弄坏地毯。”你就会说：“嘿，我可以绕着地毯走吗？”我会说：“哦，是的，你应该从后门进来的。我们可以解决这个问题。”
We can work this out. Because there are so many assumptions built in to the way we talk about racism, we end up establishing positions before we've even listened to anybody's interests. And so the thing that was shocking to me, I'm a black dude from Philly. I figured when I showed up talking along for us, but I would find out that racist, racist did racist things.
我们可以解决它。因为我们谈论种族主义的方式中内置了太多的假设，以至于我们甚至在倾听任何人的利益之前，就已经确立了各自的立场。所以令我震惊的是，我是一个来自费城的黑人小伙子。我想象当我出现在执法部门谈论这些时，我会发现种族主义者做了种族主义的事情。
That's still true, but the majority of folks I encountered were like, oh, we get asked to do too much stuff. And we're definitely, we're going to catch hell in the press and from communities that we really care about in large part because we get asked to do stuff. We should never get asked to do So when you compare the the requests that I've received from law enforcement of the last 20 plus years To the requests that I I hear from activists. They look really similar Law enforcement says get us out of mental health get us out of substance abuse get us out of child welfare Like remove us out of the schools.
这仍然是真的，但我遇到的大多数人都在说：“哦，我们被要求做太多事情了。而且我们在很大程度上肯定会受到媒体和我们真正关心的社区的严厉谴责，很大程度上是因为我们被要求做那些我们永远不应该被要求做的事情。”所以，当你把我过去20多年里从执法部门收到的请求与我从维权人士那里听到的请求进行比较时，它们看起来非常相似。执法部门说：“把我们从心理健康危机中撤出来，把我们从药物滥用中撤出来，把我们从儿童福利中撤出来。把我们从学校里移开。”
Don't ask us to be on suicide watch. Set up resources so that these communities that are blighted by crime have the thing so they don't have to engage in crime in the first place. If I were to tell you that came out of the mouth of an abolitionist, you wouldn't be surprised. The major difference is law enforcement doesn't usually argue that they should get less money. An activist right about now arguing for that quite loudly. But the substantive policy changes outside of law enforcement have a lot of support from law enforcement veterans, which I think is especially surprising to folks who are just
“不要要求我们去进行自杀监视。建立资源，让这些饱受犯罪祸害的社区拥有他们所需的东西，这样他们一开始就不必犯罪。”如果我告诉你这些话出自一个废奴主义者之口，你不会感到惊讶。主要的区别在于，执法部门通常不会辩称他们应该获得更少的资金。而激进分子现在正为之大声疾呼。但是执法部门以外的实质性政策变化得到了执法老兵的大量支持，我认为这对于那些刚刚听到国家对话的人来说尤其令人惊讶。在拉斯维加斯之行几年后，菲利普和他的团队开始研究另一个想法。
hearing the national conversation. A few years after his walk in Las Vegas, Philip and his team began studying another idea. Think back to the case involving Dante Wright. Shortly after that shooting, people spent a lot of time arguing about whether the police officer who pulled the trigger acted out of malice. Few people stopped to ask a more basic question. Should armed police officers be pulling over drivers for expired tags? Turned out, this was also a question both the local community and the police were pondering in California. The Berkeley
回想一下涉及丹特·赖特的案件。在那场枪击事件发生后不久，人们花了很多时间争论扣动扳机的警察是否出于恶意。很少有人停下来问一个更基本的问题：全副武装的警察是否应该因为车牌过期而拦下司机？事实证明，这也是加州当地社区和警察正在思索的一个问题。伯克利
Police Chief reached out in part because of pressure from communities in Berkeley, California, and they had the idea to look at what are we doing on traffic stops. If you've got a lot of physical violence in a place that would never have happened if you didn't show up, the best solution might be don't show up. The old joke is, hey, Doc, it hurts when I go like this. Doc says, don't go like that. And in Berkeley, they decided any low-level traffic enforcement let us mail you a ticket. Because that's going to be safer for the officer. That's going to be safer for the resident.
警察局长主动联系，部分原因是来自加利福尼亚州伯克利市社区的压力，他们当时的想法是审视我们在交通拦截中究竟在做什么。如果你在一个地方遇到了大量本可在你未出现时就不会发生的身体暴力，最好的解决方案可能就是不要出现。老笑话是，嘿，医生，我这么做时这里疼。医生说，那就别那样做。在伯克利，他们决定任何低级别的交通执法都改为通过邮件向你寄送罚单。因为这对警官来说更安全。这对居民来说更安全。
And likely nobody dies from a paper cut. To be clear, Philip is not saying there is never room for armed police. He's saying, ask yourself if an officer with a badge and a gun needs to be your first response to a problem. If someone is driving around with expired tags and you can send them a ticket in the mail, they might just pay the fine and get that tax renewed, problem solved. If they don't respond to the ticket, you can then think of escalating your response. The very same principle applies to the use of no-knock warrants. Philip told me about a local jurisdiction in
而且大概没有人会因为纸划伤而丧命。需要明确的是，菲利普并不是说武装警察永远没有存在的空间。他是说，扪心自问一下，一个带着警徽和枪支的警官是否真的需要成为你应对问题的第一反应。如果有人开着过期车牌的车到处转悠，而你可以把罚单寄到他们家里，他们可能就会乖乖交罚款并更新税标，问题就解决了。如果他们对罚单置之不理，你再考虑升级应对措施。同样的原则也适用于无搜查令搜查的使用。菲利普向我讲述了当地的一个司法管辖区
New York that asked for help. We got involved with Ithaca and Tomkins County that wanted to do this together. And so it's really important. It is really their work that we're talking about here. They brought school-aged kids in to hear about their experiences and to say, well, if we wanted to start over, start from scratch, how what would that look like? If we really focused on protecting folks who were vulnerable, what systems would we build?
纽约州的一个寻求帮助的地区。我们参与了伊萨卡和汤普金斯县的项目，他们希望共同完成这件事。所以这真的很重要。我们在这里谈论的确实是他们的工作。他们把正值学龄的孩子们请来，倾听他们的经历并探讨：如果我们想从头开始、白手起家，那会是什么样子？如果我们真正专注于保护弱势群体，我们会建立什么样的系统？
And it turns out that when you start that exercise, you don't start with police. You don't start with folks who have the ability to dole out violence in order to get compliance with the law. You start with the basic necessities of living. And so the Communities in Ithaca and Tomkens County said, well, we're gonna want folks who can respond to violence, but we want them directed by folks who are thinking about
事实证明，当你开始这项练习时，你不会从警察开始。你不会从那些为了让人们服从法律而拥有施加暴力权力的人开始。你要从生活的基本需求开始。因此，伊萨卡和汤普金斯县的社区表示，好吧，我们会需要能够应对暴力的人，但我们希望他们听从那些致力于以下事情的人的指挥：
community solutions to public safety that will often not require law enforcement. And along with that, our set of recommendations, including, yeah, we shouldn't have no knock warrants. Like we should be a community that knows who lives here well enough, that we don't have to resort to the element of surprise to deal with folks who are damaging the communities. And where the community wants those folks to stop their behavior or even to be taken out of it.
关于公共安全的社区解决方案，这些方案通常不需要执法部门介入。与此相伴的，是我们的一系列建议，包括，是的，我们不应该有无需搜查令的突击搜查。就像我们应该成为一个足够了解这里谁住在哪里的社区一样，我们不需要诉诸出其不意的元素来对付那些破坏社区的人。而且社区希望这些人停止他们的行为，甚至将他们从这种状态中带离。
You know, Philip, in some ways, I'm struck by the fact that what you're advocating and no disrespect here, it's actually not rocket science. It's almost common sense. If you want to reduce the risk that the police will shoot someone by mistake. The first thing to do is don't send armed police to situations that don't require armed police. So the hard part here is figuring out the interests and figuring out where is their room to move. Where can we get collaboration, coalition, consensus to move us forward? I say all the time, why are we bringing a badge and a gun to a place where someone's
你知道，菲利普，在某些方面，我感触很深的是，你所倡导的——无意冒犯——其实并不是什么高深莫测的科学。这几乎就是常识。如果你想降低警察误杀某人的风险。首要的做法就是不要将武装警察派往不需要武装警察的场合。所以这里的难点在于弄清楚各方的利益所在，并找出是否有妥协的空间。我们在哪里可以获得协作、联盟和共识来推动我们前进？我总是说，为什么我们要把警徽和枪支带到一个有人正
thinking about ending their own life? Philip Satsaqais where officers were called to a home where a man was pointing a gun at his own head. And the police said, that's a danger to us and Shahat end killed him. Right? That's a danger to us and shot and killed him. Right? That's a tragedy on top of tragedy because the family is concerned that this person is going to die and then calls the state and the state shows up and does it for him. But I wish it were the case that if you don't introduce a gun, the chance of getting shot
考虑结束自己生命的地方？菲利普·萨特萨盖伊斯（注：此处原文语音转写有误，应指菲利普·阿蒂巴·高夫）提到过这样一个案例：警察被叫到一处住宅，那里有一个男人正拿枪指着自己的头部。而警察却说，这对我们构成了危险，随后开枪打死了他。对吧？那是对我们构成了危险，所以开枪打死了他。对吧？这简直是悲剧中的悲剧，因为家属担心这个人会死，于是向国家求助，而国家出面却直接帮他把这事办了。但我也希望情况是这样的：如果你不引入一把枪，中枪的机率
was zero. Unfortunately, we've got so many guns in this country that that's not the case. And that's what law enforcement and community folks will say is sometimes they're scared that if you set up somebody, show somebody with a vest in a whistle, that's not going to be enough. So I wish that this were as simple as an ideological slogan. It cannot be. But the underlying logic is exactly what you say. If our goal is to keep
会是零。不幸的是，我们国家有太多的枪支，事实并非如此。这也是执法人员和社区人士会说的话：有时他们感到害怕，如果你只派一个穿着背心、拿着哨子的人去，那可能根本不够。所以我希望这能像一个意识形态口号那样简单。它不可能那么简单。但其背后的逻辑完全正如你所说。如果我们的目标是保持
everybody safe and alive, there are lots of times when a badge and a gun are not the best things to be introducing. You know, I'm reminded of something I read a while ago. After the US invasion of Iraq, the US military was trying to figure out how troops could be more effective in rebuilding trust with a local community. And one of the things that General David Petrius eventually concluded was that if you're trying to help people, but you're looking at them through the gun turrets of an armored vehicle, or if you're walking in markets with an M14 rifle slung from your shoulders, it not only makes it less likely people will trust you
每个人安全并活着，那么在很多时候，警徽和枪支并不是最适合引入的东西。你知道，我想起了一段时间前我读到的某段内容。美国入侵伊拉克后，美军一直在设法弄清楚军队如何才能更有效地重建与当地社区的信任。戴维·彼得雷乌斯将军最终得出的结论之一是：如果你试图帮助人们，但你却透过装甲车的枪塔看着他们，或者你手里端着M14步枪在集市中巡逻，这不仅会降低人们信任你的可能性，
It makes it more likely some small incident can end up with a whole lot of people getting shot So it turns out even in military situations Military-ized solutions might end up backfiring and of course if that's true in battle It has to be triply true when it comes to police working in their communities when everyone is is tense, everyone is scared, and everyone is armed, even in the absence of malice, the simple laws of probability dictate bad things are going to happen with some regularity. That's exactly right, and the analogy is apt. Over the last three decades, we've seen a precipitous decline in violent crime across the United States. That is the result of a whole bunch of things. It's community focused projects,
反而更有可能让一些小摩擦最终导致一大群人中枪。因此事实证明，即使是在军事局势中，军事化的解决方案也可能最终适得其反；当然，如果这在战场上成立的话，当警察在自己的社区工作时，这就更必须是三倍成立了——在每个人都神经紧绷、每个人都感到害怕、每个人都武装到牙齿的情况下，即使没有恶意的存在，简单的概率法则也注定会以一定的规律发生坏事。完全正确，这个类比非常贴切。在过去三十年中，我们看到全美暴力犯罪率急剧下降。这是许多因素共同作用的结果。它是以社区为核心的项目，
it is leadership at the local and the state level, but it's also new techniques in law enforcement of showing up, not arresting the way out of the problem, but showing up to places where violence might happen, and people tend not to like to do illegal things in the presence of law enforcement. Like that's a portion of it, even though it's definitely not the only, and it may not even be the largest portion of it.
它是地方和州一级的领导力，但它也是执法部门的新技术——到场执勤，而不是用逮捕来解决问题，而是出现在可能发生暴力的地方，而且人们往往不愿意在执法人员在场的情况下做违法的事情。这只是其中的一部分，尽管它绝对不是全部，甚至可能都不是最大的一部分。
So if I'm law enforcement, I have worked my behind-off to try and reduce the crime level because I thought that was my job. And I know that if I'm a chief, I'm definitely getting fired if the crime level goes up, and that's almost the only reason I'm going to get fired. I brought the crime level down, why don't you love us? That's a real thing that law enforcement feels, and I don't think it's a response that's untethered to reality.
所以如果我是执法人员，我已经拼尽全力试图降低犯罪率，因为我认为那是我的工作。而且我知道，如果我是一名局长，如果犯罪率上升，我肯定会被解雇，而这几乎是我被解雇的唯一原因。我把犯罪率降下来了，你们为什么不爱我们呢？这是执法部门真实存在的感受，而且我认为这种反应并非脱离现实。
It's just untethered to the experiences in black and brown communities where they say you have been delivering violence while you've been trying to deliver us from violence. I find it fascinating that you're effectively addressing problems related to racial disparities in policing without accusing police officers of being bigots. There's very little finger pointing in your work, right? Yes, so in my day to day when I'm talking with law enforcement when I'm talking with communities, when I'm talking with my team, we talk about race and racism a whole lot. What we don't talk about
它只是脱离了黑人和棕色人种社区的经历——在这些社区里，人们会说，当你们试图把我们从暴力中拯救出来时，你们自己却一直在施加暴力。我发现一个迷人的现象：你实际上在解决与警务中种族差异相关的问题时，并没有指责警官们是顽固的偏执狂。你的工作中几乎没有什么指责，对吧？是的，所以在我的日常生活中，当我与执法部门交谈时，当我与社区交谈时，当我与我的团队交谈时，我们会大量谈论种族和种族主义。我们不谈论的是
is whether or not you met two or are a good person. We don't talk about character, almost ever. But everybody who can answer the question, would you like to kill fewer people? Would you like to be engaged in less racial disparity? Yes, I would like to do that, morally obvious thing. There are things that can be done, but we don't have to talk about racism the way most people talk about racism, because the way most people talk about racism is about what kind of person you are, and I have found that to be almost entirely irrelevant to making the problem get better. Philips efforts to reduce racial disparities in policing have been effective. But are they emotionally satisfying?
你到底是不是个好人。我们几乎从不谈论品格。但是每个人都可以回答这个问题：你难道不想少杀几个人吗？你难道不想减少种族差异吗？是的，我想做这件在道德上显而易见的事情。有些事情是可以做的，但我们不必以大多数人谈论种族主义的方式去谈论它，因为大多数人谈论种族主义的方式总是关乎你是什么样的人，而我发现这对于让问题变好几乎毫无关联。菲利普为减少警务中种族差异所做出的努力一直是有效的。但它们在情感上能得到满足吗？
That's when we come back. You'll listen to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For years now, working closely with communities and police departments, Yale University Psychologist Philip Pateba Gough has sought to reduce racial disparities in law enforcement. Every time he and his organization, the Center for Policing Equity go into a community, they start by looking at the data. When and where are police using force? What are the specific contexts and situations that make it more likely? An officer will reach for a gun.
广告之后我们再回来。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆。多年来，耶鲁大学心理学家菲利普·阿蒂巴·高夫一直与社区和警察部门密切合作，致力于减少执法过程中的种族差异。每当他和他的组织“警务公平中心”进入一个社区时，他们总是从查看数据开始。警察在何时何地使用武力？有哪些具体的背景和情况使得警察更有可能
Are there situations that can be safely resolved by someone who doesn't have a badge in a gun? Philip, you've worked with the community and the police department in Minneapolis since 2015. You found that in a disproportionate number of situations where police end up using force, there's one particular group of people involved. Who are they? Whenever we're going into a community, the first thing we do we want to listen to the community. In Minneapolis, one of the areas that was a concern was homelessness. I don't know if you've ever been to Minneapolis, but unless it's June or July, it's cold, and it sucks to have to be outside and not have a place you can go that's inside.
伸手去拿枪？是否存在某些情况，可以由一个没有警徽和枪支的人安全地解决？菲利普，你自2015年以来一直与明尼阿波利斯的社区和警察部门合作。你发现，在警察最终使用武力的大量失衡情况中，总是涉及某一个特定群体。他们是谁？每当我们进入一个社区，我们要做的第一件事就是倾听社区的声音。在明尼阿波利斯，令人担忧的领域之一是无家可归问题。我不知道你有没有去过明尼阿波利斯，但除非是六月或七月，那里非常寒冷，待在户外却没有一个可以进去的避身之所，这种感觉糟透了。
So folks end up in places where they can stay warm, but what that also does, it makes people feel uncomfortable. And so they call the police law enforcement shows up. Someone who doesn't have a place to live says, I'm not done anything illegal, so they resist law enforcement, and then force ensues. You could train law enforcement to recognize that and talk differently about it, or you could give people housing. This is the thing that is the core of my frustration in doing this work,
因此，人们最终会去那些能让他们保持温暖的地方，但这也会带来另一个后果：它会让人们感到不舒服。于是他们报警，执法人员随即赶到。一个无家可归的人说，我没有做任何违法的事，于是他们抗拒执法，随之便引发了武力冲突。你可以训练执法人员识别这一点并以不同的方式进行沟通，或者你可以给人们提供住房。这就是我在从事这项工作时感到核心沮丧的地方，
is that oftentimes the only path available to make anything better is to give something to law enforcement. But you could just avoid all of this by having a warm place for people to sleep. And so when communities activists within Minneapolis were saying, hey, we need money for this. We provided some data that said, hey, you should do what the community is asking. Take money out of law enforcement, put it into services for out-housed individuals, and you can start to see if you should force go down. So there's something both satisfying and profoundly dissatisfying about your work.
那就是通常能够让事情变好的唯一途径，就是向执法部门提供某些东西。但你本可以通过为人们提供一个温暖的睡觉地方来避免这一切。因此，当明尼阿波利斯的社区活动人士在说“嘿，我们需要这方面的资金”时，我们提供了一些数据说：“嘿，你们应该按照社区的要求去做。把资金从执法部门抽离出来，投入到无家可归者的服务中，你就会开始看到武力是否会减少。”因此，你的工作既有一些令人满意的地方，也有一些让人深深感到不满意的地方。
It's satisfying because you're making a difference, but I think one reason people might feel almost let down by your work is it doesn't give us a feeling of moral triumph by focusing on what's practical, by focusing on areas where police and communities are in consensus, I feel we miss out on the opportunity for moral triumph. And that's a feeling we definitely get when we share hot takes on social media. Yes, the work that I do is not designed to satisfy Twitter. That is a thousand percent accurate. I think there's a deeper thing here as well, which is that it is hard to keep people's
它令人满意是因为你正在带来改变，但我认为人们可能会对你的工作感到失望的一个原因，是它没有通过关注实际、通过关注警察和社区达成共识的领域，来给我们带来道德凯旋的感觉，我觉得我们因此失去了获得道德凯旋的机会。当我们分享社交媒体上的热门言论时，我们绝对能得到这种感觉。是的，我的工作不是为了迎合推特设计的。这百分之一千是准确的。我认为这里还有一个更深层次的问题，那就是，如果你没有一个反派，要让人们的注意力保持在一个如此悲剧的故事上是很难的。
attention on a story that is so tragic if you don't have a villain. And it's easy to make some of these folks villains because they're villainous. Individual cases, absolutely. The problem is, oftentimes, once you've activated based on that narrative, then the theory of the problem is, well, then we got to get rid of this person or these people and you're right back where you started. We talked earlier about your work in Minneapolis. Now, as we all know, a few years later, Minneapolis was the same city in which George Floyd was killed by an officer after a convenience store clerk called 911.
要把其中一些人塑造成反派很容易，因为他们确实十恶不赦。个别案件，绝对如此。问题在于，通常一旦你根据这种叙事采取行动，那么对这个问题的理论解释就是：好吧，那我们必须除掉这个人或这些人，然后你又回到了原点。我们刚才谈到了你在明尼阿波利斯的工作。现在，众所周知，几年后，明尼阿波利斯成了乔治·弗洛伊德在便利店店员拨打911后被一名警官杀害的同一座城市。
Now, some people might say, look, your approach is fixing the problem around the edges. It isn't getting to the heart of the problem. It doesn't prevent egregious cases like this one from happening. Yeah, the public lynching of George Floyd was gutting for the whole country. The three years that we were there, we saw about an 18% reduction in police use of force. So the three years before we were there, um, police use of force was on the rise. Now, did we cause that decline? I do not know.
现在，有些人可能会说，看吧，你的方法只是在边缘修修补补。它没有触及问题的核心。它无法防止像这样骇人听闻的案件再次发生。是的，乔治·弗洛伊德被当众杀害对整个国家来说都是沉重的打击。我们在那里的三年里，我们看到警察使用武力的情况减少了大约18%。所以我们在那之前的三年前，嗯，警察使用武力的情况一直在上升。现在，是我们导致了这种下降吗？我不知道。
So who knows how much of that was us and how much of that was the demands of organizers, how much of that was all together. It's, it's, it's genuinely difficult to say. And we weren't set up to test that very squarely. But if there's some portion of the work that we were doing that resulted in one in five fewer people having forced use on them, that's not nothing. All of these things are harm reduction. They're reducing the harms of our addiction to punishment in this country.
所以谁知道其中有多少是我们的功劳，有多少是组织者的诉求带来的，又有多少是共同作用的结果。这真的很难说。而且我们的设定也不是为了非常精确地测试这一点。但如果我们所做的工作中有一部分使得遭遇武力使用的人减少了五分之一，那也不是无足轻重的。所有这些都是伤害减免。它们减少了我们这个国家对惩罚成瘾所带来的伤害。
That is not ever going to be the full solve. But I look at this and I say, this was a tragic incident. It was absolutely predictable, not necessarily Minneapolis, but anywhere where any of this work is going on. It doesn't negate the work that communities did to drive down police use of force, and it doesn't mean that we should be throwing out some of the things that have reduced the harm. I love that you're using the framework of harm reduction, and I feel like we've had similar
这永远不会成为彻底的解决方案。但我看着这一切，心想：这是一起悲剧事件。它是完全可以预见的——不一定是在明尼阿波利斯，而是在任何开展这类工作的其他地方。这并没有否定社区为压低警察武力使用所做的工作，也不意味着我们应该抛弃那些已经减少了伤害的做法。我很高兴你使用了“伤害减免”的框架，我觉得我们在谈到诸如在学校分发避孕套或向海洛因瘾君子提供清洁针头之类的事情时，也有过类似的
debates when it comes to things like distributing condoms in schools or giving clean needles to heroin addicts. There's something so seductive about wanting answers that are all or nothing, you know, just say no to drugs, abstinence only. How reduction says, if there's a small win to be taken, take it. It's not enough, but not enough is better than nothing. I've been black my entire life. I have seen promises. I've seen, you know, leaders say what they could deliver, and I have never been part of a moment that didn't feel ultimately disappointed, ultimately less than what was necessary.
辩论。想要非黑即白的答案有着巨大的诱惑力，你知道的，比如对毒品说不，只主张禁欲。而伤害减免则认为，如果能取得哪怕一点微小的胜利，也要把它拿下。这还不够，但不够总比什么都没有强。我一辈子都是黑人。我见过许许多多的承诺。我见过，你知道的，领导者们信誓旦旦地保证他们能兑现什么，而我从未经历过一个最终不会让人感到失望、最终达不到必要程度的时刻。
And anyone who tells you that they can fix it all is singing songs from the music man. That is literally a fantastical musical untethered to what's possible. There's another dimension of your work I want to flag because I think it comes up all the time and the choices we make as a society. So much of what you're recommending is unsexy. It's about prevention. It's not seeing something awful happen and reacting to it. It's asking, how do we keep the bad stuff from happening in the first place? And like all successful prevention efforts, when it works, no one notices because the bad thing never actually happened. So, you know, unsexy might be effective, but you have to admit it's also unsexy.
任何告诉你他们能彻底解决所有问题的人，都是在唱着空洞的调子。那简直是一个脱离现实的幻想音乐剧。我想指出你工作的另一个维度，因为我认为它在我们作为社会所做出的选择中不断出现。你所推荐的很多东西都毫无吸引力。它关乎预防。它不是指看到可怕的事情发生然后再做出反应。它是去追问：我们如何才能从一开始就防止坏事发生？就像所有成功的预防工作一样，当它起作用时，没有人会注意到，因为坏事根本没有发生。所以，你知道，缺乏吸引力可能也是有效的，但你必须承认它确实缺乏吸引力。
So first in response, I want to stick my claim to being the king of unsexy. That is absolutely who I am and what I do. Secondly, this is a part of my concern for the narrative work that's happening right now, where there's a promulgation of villains. Because a villain framing for all of this work ends up with the goal, catch them, punish them. Let's hold them accountable. And we hear battle cries for justice for Breonna Taylor or justice for George Floyd.
所以首先作为回应，我要宣称自己是“无趣之王”。这绝对是我本人以及我所做的事情。其次，这也是我对当前正在发生的叙事工作感到担忧的一部分，因为现在到处都在宣扬反派。因为所有这些工作的反派叙事框架，最终导向的目标就是：抓住他们，惩罚他们。让我们追究他们的责任。我们听到为布里安娜·泰勒或乔治·弗洛伊德伸张正义的战斗呐喊。
There is no such thing. Justice would have been them staying alive. But most local organizers that we engage are actually saying, let's prevent these things from happening in the first place, let's equip communities with the resources, so they don't have to call out in crisis at all. Like what neighborhood sells houses, what neighborhood has a real estate agent who says,
根本没有这种事。正义本该是他们活着。但我们接触的大多数本地组织者实际上都在说：让我们从一开始就防止这些事情发生，让我们为社区配备资源，这样他们根本不需要在危机时刻大声呼救。就像哪个社区会推销房屋，哪个社区会有房地产经纪人说：
hey, the best part about living here, you get to call 911 all the time. It's amazing. That's not a thing. Like the places where people want to live have the resources so they don't have to call out in crisis. Most of the activists who are doing serious work in local spaces are working on that on getting the resources set up or getting alternative crisis responders set up so that law enforcement is not our utility tool to handle every crisis
嘿，住在这里最好的地方就是你可以一直打911。这太棒了。根本没有这种事。那些人们想要居住的地方都拥有充足的资源，因此他们不必在危机时刻大声求助。大多数在基层开展严肃工作的活动人士都在致力于此——争取建立资源配置，或者建立替代性的危机应对人员，这样执法部门就不会成为我们用来处理每一个危机的万能工具了。
that happens in the communities that we'd like to forget existed. Something odd often happens when you take the small winds and chip away at a problem. Each effort, each change, can seem incremental, but over time, Philip says, it's like a snow ball rolling down a hill. Oftentimes the harm reduction is the way in to engage in more radical change. And sometimes the things that you do that turn the dial slightly, it's like falling asleep, happen slowly and then all at once. Oftentimes that is the way in which radical social change takes place, is a step and a
在我们希望假装它不存在的社区里发生的危机。当你取得微小的胜利并一点点啃掉一个问题时，往往会发生一些奇怪的事情。每一项努力、每一个改变似乎都微乎其微，但随着时间的推移，菲利普说，这就像一个从山上滚下来的雪球。通常，伤害减免是参与更激进变革的切入点。有时，你所做的那些稍微拨动表盘的事情——就像入睡一样，过程缓慢，然后一气呵成。通常这就是激进社会变革发生的方式，那就是一步、
step and a step and then a fall. And my hope is that's where we're headed in terms of keeping black community safe, a step and a step and a step, and a step, and then a fall. A fall into a more prosperous country, a more equal country, where folks have the resources they need to not have to crawl out crisis in the first place, where we send the appropriate resources, which are not always a badge and a gun,
一步、一步，然后水到渠成。而我的希望，正是我们朝着保障黑人社区安全迈进的方向：一步、一步、一步，再一步，然后水到渠成。水到渠成般地迈向一个更加繁荣的国家、一个更加平等的国家，在那里人们拥有他们所需的资源，从而不必在一开始就陷于危机之中；在那里，当我们面临危机时，我们会派出适当的资源（这并不总是警徽和枪支），
when they do have a crisis, and where all of those things we're doing to change the systems that we have, don't impede the creation and the destruction of the systems that we need to move forward. For anybody who's feeling, you know, despondent right now, what I would say is I think that often hopelessness is a luxury. think that often hopelessness is a luxury. It's not an option for the people who are working hardest in this space because hopelessness is the end of the work and we're just at the beginning. Philip Attiba Gough is a psychologist at Yale University.
并且我们为改变现有系统而做的一切努力，不会阻碍我们构建和破除向前发展所需的系统。对于任何此刻感到沮丧的人，我想说的是，我认为绝望往往是一种奢侈品。我认为绝望往往是一种奢侈品。对于在这个领域里付出最多努力的人来说，它并不是一个选项，因为绝望意味着工作的终结，而我们其实才刚刚开始。菲利普·阿蒂巴·高夫是耶鲁大学的心理学家。
Along with Tracy Kazee, he is co-founder of the Center for Policing Equity. Philip, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Simon Owens.
他和特蕾西·卡齐（Tracy Kazee）一起，是警务公平中心的共同创始人。菲利普，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。本期《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、瑞恩·卡茨、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、奥秋姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是西蒙·欧文斯。
Simon is a tech journalist who runs a newsletter about trends in the media industry. It's a wonderful resource for podcasters. Simon recently made time to chat with us and he had some useful suggestions on how to grow our newsletter audience. Thank you so much for your insight, Simon. Speaking of our newsletter, you can read it and subscribe at news.hiddenbrain.org. Every week, we bring you interesting research
西蒙是一位科技记者，他运营着一份关于媒体行业趋势的简报。对于播客制作者来说，这是一个极好的资源。西蒙最近抽出时间与我们聊天，并就如何扩大我们的简报受众提出了许多有用的建议。非常感谢你的真知灼见，西蒙。说到我们的简报，你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 阅读并订阅。每周我们都会为你带来关于人类行为的有趣研究，
about human behavior, as well as a brain teaser and a moment of joy. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐的时刻。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦姆，我们很快再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。